después de la lluvia y el viento hong
kong ha renacido de sus cenizas lo ha
dicho hoy el presidente chino xi jinping
tras llegar a la excolonia y sin
aclararse con esas metáforas aludía a la
pandemia que ha atacado este año con
fuerza el territorio o aquellas
protestas masivas de 2019 si ha
calificado de éxito la fórmula de un
país dos sistemas a pesar de que muchos
con con eses consideran que la ley de
seguridad nacional aprobada para sofocar
aquellas protestas supuso el fin de
aquella fórmula ideada por deng xiaoping
este es el primer viaje del presidente
fuera de la china continental en más de
dos años y medio de pandemia y todo se
ha preparado para asegurar el éxito y
para alejar cualquier conato de protesta
varias estaciones de metro se han
cerrado varias rutas de autobús han sido
redireccionadas y un doble cinturón de
seguridad rodea al centro de
convenciones uno de los escasos grupos
prodemocráticos que resisten ha aclarado
ya que no va a organizar ningún acto de
protesta después de que la policía
llamara a algunos de sus miembros el
objetivo de si a hong kong es doble por
un lado asistir a la celebración del 25
aniversario
del regreso de la excolonia a la madre
patria y por otro asistir también a la
investidura de jong lee el nuevo jefe
ejecutivo y que antes fuera encargado de
la seguridad y que supervisará la
campaña contra los grupos
prodemocráticos